please stop harassing Mr Craig I
apologize in advance
this is my friend Ash I think I I
thought this was a very bad idea okay
yeah ever since I saw Tomb Raider I just
can't contain myself
right Ryan do you feel is this a
blessing or a curse for you it was a
blessing oh my God what else is he gonna
say
yeah
well I'm I forgot to see you both I have
a bit of a confession at the junket we
did a little accent challenge where we
had everyone do the Benoit Blanc accent
someone showed it to me yeah yeah don't
expect me to do it
they were bad
Benoit blanc no clearly
well this is delightful Halle Berry
Halle Berry that has a kick you have a
guess of who did the best yeah Janelle
Janelle I was I was thinking it's
Janelle uh that Southern drawl
ladies and gentlemen I'm gonna stop
right there in the moment I was like
she's actually nailing this yeah yeah
well she's also she's she's got the
southern you know she has family in the
South yeah she's from yeah the South
also completely [ __ ] me up makes sense
but yeah yeah Edward Norton told us also
that Daniel that you're more Benoit
Blanc than Bond do you agree with that
and could you see yourself away
stay away for two days
[Laughter]
chaos
than Jim than James
I mean like I don't know what to say to
them
thanks Edward
so do you see yourself playing Ben wall
block as long as you did Bond
sure I mean and we've had this
conversation I mean if Ryan keeps
writing them I I won't say no I mean
it's as simple as that um I think you
know when we made the first come on we
thought it was funny
you know we we'd laughed when we watched
it we thought it was funny whether
anybody else finds it funny that's kind
of like that's the big you know it's the
64 000 question isn't it it's like and
they did they appeared to so the same
applied to this one we think it's funny
we hope it's funny we want people to get
massive amounts of joy out of it and it
seems to be people are reacting to it so
as long as we can do that we can make
that happen we'll I think we'll have a
go at doing it you're all friends why
would anyone commit murder
are we even gonna talk about the
elephant in the room am I the elephant
yeah you're the elephant you're not that
bad I think it's even funnier I have to
say good I'll take it okay
well uh more musings from the junket
that Daniel wasn't there for we learned
that Daniel always walks around on set
with a 90s style Walkman I think
Janelle's was saying this I remember you
a tea Style no I think it's just that
everybody literally it's an old iPod
it might be an old iPod Touch it's not a
90s
books I would love that I mean I like an
80s
one of The Originals that would be uh
that would be amazing sadly I don't have
enough tapes left anymore there's some
lying around somewhere but my mixtapes
have all died
sounds like this whole junk it was just
lies told about Daniel you're good at
their actors they like the living they
just make up
I was just gonna ask what you were
listening to
see you touched a nerve clearly
I have it I have it on on um
a shuffle I've got one of those iPods
that literally is a connected to my CD
collection which I like
I transferred everything to my apple
back way back in the day and got rid of
all my CDs I don't know why because I
love CDs
um and so I've got all that then I've
got the new stuff and I've got all this
old stuff and then I've got somehow back
in the day when you could sort of share
stuff so I have other people's
Collections and it's all kind of updated
so it is so Random I just stick things
on and things either surprise me or I
jog it on when it's embarrassing what's
the most surprising thing on your iPod
you're playing you play it in public
there's no judgment that's why
I was judging
[Music]